네 안녕하세요 빌사남 벌써 여러분들
올해 12월 어 말을 향해서 지금
가고 있는데 올해 매각된 사례 중에
저희가 알만한 지역 있잖아요 알만한
지역에 높은 금액대로 어 매각된 그런
사례들을 좀 정리해 봤습니다 일단은
첫 번째로 명동에 있는 건물인데 지금
위치는 여기 대로변 코너에 있어요
그래서 땅 모양은 지금 이렇게 얇게
돼 있습니다 그래서 대지 면적이
14평이에요 연면적이 한 74평 정도
그래서 지금 보면은이 건물입니다
굉장히 좀 오래된 그런 건물이죠
그래서 옆에 보시면은 이렇게 얇아요
되게 얇죠 그래서 지금이 건물이
돼지가 14평 옆면적 74평 매매가는
11억에 어 매각이 됐습니다 짜 돼지
평단가를 봤을 때는 7억 8천 정도의
예 매각이 된 그런 사례입니다 아마
이거 딱 그냥 건물만 보시면 깜짝
놀라실 거예요 어 이게 110억이야
어 위치나 이런게 좀 어 그래도 좋은
편이어서 어 일단 이렇게 매각된
사례가 있습니다 그 두 번째로는 어
신사역 앞에 있는 건물인데
도산대로에서 위치가 제일 좋아요
아무래도 위치가 좋다 보니까 도산대로
해선 좀 제일 높게 매각이 됐습니다
대지 면적이 한 100평이 조금 안
되고 돼지 평당가로 봤을 때는 5억
정도의 이제 매각이 된 그런 건물이고
그리고 여기 같은 경우에는 노선
상업지에 상업지 비율이 좀 높습니다
그래서 만약에 건물 나중에 올리게
되면 용적률을 꽤 많이 받을 만한 어
그런 건물이고 대부분 다 이제 신사역
8번 출구에서 만나거든요 유동인구가
굉장히 많은 곳이고 그 가로 스킬
가려면 무조건 이쪽으로 와요 위치는
너무 좋다 그리고 성수동에 또 매각된
사례가 있는데 여기 아뜰리에 길
메인에 있는 건물이에요 그래서 여기
초입에 들어가서 바로 코너에 있는
건물인데 돼지가 50평 정도 근데
87억 5천만 원에 매입을 했어요네
그래서 대지 평당가로 봤을 때는 한
1억 7천 정도의 매각된 그런
사례입니다
그래서 보면은 여기 아뜰리에 길에는
어 일단 유동 인군 너무 많아요네
유동인구 너무 많은데 일단은 지금
성수동이 대부분 중공업 지역이 많은데
여기 같은 경우에 중공업 지역은
아니에요 그래서 지금 2종이나 이제
3종 주어 지역 있는 곳이고 아뜰리에
길에 메인에 있는 위치 좋은 위치지만
중공업 지역이 아닌데 1억 7천 중도
매각이 됐다 여러분들이 좀 알고
계시면 좋을 거 같고 최근에 이제 또
매각된 사례인데 연무장길 제가 아
유튜브로도 찍었는데 무신사에서 이제
신축한 그 건물도 매각이 됐어요
그래서 돼지가 46평이고 연면적이
3185 있니다 86평 아무래도
여기가 중공업 지역이다 보니까 건물을
굉장히 좀 높게 졌죠 그래서요 사례도
건물을 거의 이제 지는지 얼마 안
돼서 이제 매각 했더라고요 요것도
매각이 어
11억에 매각을 했고 연면적당
가격으로 봤을 때는 한 3,500만
원 정도의 매각이 됐고 대지 평단가
나 2억 7천 정도 매각이 됐습니다
그래서 지금 연무 장기은 한 2억
정도의 거래 사례들도 있고 매물도 그
이상으로 나오는 거 같아요 대로변이
아닌 연무장 길에 좀이 정도의 거래가
되고 있다네 여러분들 좀 알고 계시면
좋을 것 같고 그리고 홍대 쪽에
사례도 좀 자주하는데 여기 홍대
입구역 어 8번 출과 앞에 있는 여기
코너 땅 위치는 너무 좋죠 보통 홍대
갈 때 이제 이쪽으로 좀 많이 길을
이용해서 가는데 여기도 대지간 4
18평 정도 되고 연면적이 177
있니다 지하 1층의 지상 5층
건물인데 돼지 평당가로 봤을 때는 한
2억 정도 그니까 95억 매각이
됐습니다 홍대 입구역 메인 초입에 한
2억 정도의 매각이 됐다 이렇게
보시면 될 거 같고 그리고 또
마지막으로는 저기 이제 해운대 지금
보면은 여기 이제 해운대 앞에
우동이네 우동 그 뭐 먹는 우동이
아니라 아지 죄송합니다 아무튼 우동이
우동에 여기 그 신라스테이 뒤쪽
코너에 있던 호텔이 들어가 있다
건물이 매각이 됐습니다요 건물이죠요
건물이 매각이 됐고 돼지가
110평이고 그다음 연면적이 571평
22억에 매각이 됐고요 그래서 대지
평당가로 봤을 때는 한 2억 정도의
매각이 됐습니다 그래서 진짜 해운대도
이제 좀 위치 좋은 데는 한 2억
정도 되는구나 그래서 태운데도 가격이
꽤 많이 비싸죠 그래서 렇게 매각이
됐던 그런 사례들이 있는데 여러분들은
좀 어떤 사례를 좀 흥미롭게 보셨는지
좀 정리를 해보자면 어 명동 대로변의
코너에 14평 연면적 171 짜리가
이제 110억 땅 가격만 7억 8천
정도인게 일단은 되게 좀 인상 깊었고
그다음에 도산대로 위치 제일 좋은게
한 5억 정도 매각이 된 사례도 되게
인상이 깊고 그다음에 성수동 아뜰리에
길 초입의 코너에 있는 건물이 한
1억 7천 중공 지도 아닌데 그다음에
무신사가 있는 연무장길 그쪽이 이면이
한데 뭐 지금 땅 가격만 2억이 넘게
거래되는 그런 사례도 되게 흥미로웠고
홍대 뭐 바로 이제 초입에 2억
해운대 이제 한 2억 정도에
매각되는게 새롭기도 했습니다 제가 좀
이렇게 지역마다 좀 정리를 했는데
여러분들 어떠셨나요 영상을 시상식
느낌으로 좀 앞으로 찍어 보려고 해요
그래서이 지금 여러 지역에 재밌는
특이한 아니면 인상깊은 그런 사례들을
정 에서 영상을 좀 찍어 보려고
하는데 여러분들 궁금해하시는 거
아니면은 좀 이런 순위를 좀 정했으면
좋겠다라고 하시는게 있으면 댓글 남겨
주시면 어 제가 한번 좀 준비해서
촬영을 해 보려고 합니다 아 그래서
올해 또 좀 이제 거의 마무리가 돼
가는데 연말 마무리 잘 하시고 또
건강 잘 챙기시고 그리고 뭐 살짝
내년 정망 좀 해 보자면 내년
상반기는 저는 좀 좋지 않을 거라고
예상을 해요 어찌됐든 금리가
내려가는게 좀 보여야지 그래야
거래량이 좀 상승할 거 같고 저는
지금 고객들한테 항상 말씀드리지만
정말 괜찮은 입주에 괜찮은게 아니면
안 사는게 맞습니다 정말 확실한 거만
투자하는 거를 좀 말씀드리고 싶고
대출은 최대한 좀 적게 받으시고 진짜
적금리 때 생각해서 풀 레버리지
하면은 진짜 아직까진 고금리가 그리고
금리가 갑자기 떨어지진 않을 거니까
대출을 최대한 좀 적게 받아서
투자하는 걸 좀 권해드립니다 제
개인적으로는 상반기는 좋지 않지만 뭐
제런 파울 얘기하는게 이제 뭐 내년
5월부터 아니면 내년 하반기부터 조금
괜찮아질거다 아니 뭐 금리가 좀
내려갈거다 뭐 이런 얘기가 좀 있는데
어찌됐든 그 전에는 금리를 얼 어느
정도 올릴 때 올릴지 감이 안왔어요
그래서 너무 불안했어요 그래도 뭔가
내년에는 좀 올리지 않을거다 더 내릴
거다라는 얘기가 좀 있긴 해서 내년
하반기 아니면 뭐 매 후년 쯤에는 좀
거래가 좀 회복되지 않을까네 이렇게
조심스럽게 예상을 합니다 그래서 지금
만약에 현금을 좀 가지고 계신 분들은
지켜 봤다가 진짜 괜찮은 입지에
괜찮은 건물이 나오면 이렇게 투자를
한번 생각해 보시는게 좋을 거 같고
21년도 그때 이제 한찬 거래 많이
될 때죠 진짜 유동성 잔치 때 그때는
돈이 있어도 건물을 살 수가 없었어요
살려 그러면 갑자기 금액을 올리고
계약 자리에서 갑자기 도망가고 안
판다 그러고 그런 경우가 되게
많았는데 요즘에는 그래도 매도 인문이
협상이 되거든요 금액 조정을 한다든지
조건을 좀 좋게 한다든지 그래서
현금을 가지고 계신 분들은 좀 좋은
시장이긴 합니다 제가 말씀드렸던 거
기억을 하셨다가 말씀드 드린 걸
가지고 한번 좀 투자를 생각해 보시는
것도 좋을 것 같고요 그래서 오늘
영상은 여기까지 하고요 어 제가 몇
가지 사례 말씀드렸는데 여러분들이
그래도 사례들은 다들 알고 계셔야
돼요 이런 지역마다 얼마에 팔리는지
어떤게 팔리는지 알고 계셔야이 뭔가
좀 전체적인 흐름을 파악하실 수
있습니다 오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요
다음 시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다